[Music]
tonight on politics now what's on the
mind of latino voters we break down some
new polling on nevada from anderson
college
vice president kabul harris visits las
vegas to campaign for democrats the main
campaign issue she's focusing on plus
big deadlines looming for our water
supply the cuts being recommended now
and the big ones coming in the very near
future
[Music]
from 8 news now
this is politics now
very much for joining us here on
politics now i'm john langler new
insight into nevada's latino voters
research from emerson college shows the
economy is the most important issue
latinos make up about 20 percent of
nevada's voters it's a crucial part of
our population that could swing the
midterm elections one way or the other
as with most things political it starts
and ends with the economy in the emerson
college poll 37 percent of latinos think
the economy and inflation are the most
important issues housing is a distant
second followed by something else
interestingly latinos don't think either
party is best to deal with it 32 percent
don't trust democrats or republicans to
navigate the country's economic
challenges 23 percent lean towards
republicans on the issue 21 democrats
in this country in this country in this
state in this uh city
and we know that every time we go to the
store the prices seem to be higher and
higher and higher fernando romero leads
hispanics in politics the oldest latino
political group in nevada i don't see
too many speaking
on the economy and i don't see those
that prove just how
we're going to be able to solve
that particular
matter of the problem the indecisiveness
stretches into party support and
presidential approval emerson college's
polling found 36 percent are neutral on
president biden's performance 34 percent
are negative 30 positive it's more
decisive for former president trump the
new poll shows 47 percent of latinos in
nevada have a negative view of him 30
percent are neutral 23 percent are
positive it's not a matter of party it's
a matter of what the parties are doing
or not doing
the democrats are addressing what some
of our concerns are
the republicans are not among nevada
latinos voters and non-voters 42 percent
are neutral on democrats 49 percent on
republicans it's a sign both parties
have to work on their message in the
months leading up to november
we'll keep an eye on those numbers
certainly as we get closer to the
midterms meanwhile vice president kamala
harris was in las vegas this week she
campaigned for nevada democrats on
abortion rights the vice president
started though with a speech to the
steel workers union here in town then
she held a roundtable discussion with
nevada democrats including attorney
general aaron ford and senate majority
leader nicole canazzaro miss harris
focused on making abortion a central
election issue
another very important point on this
issue is that
to stand for the proposition
that the government should not interfere
in the most intimate private decision a
person can make about their body and
their future
to stand in support of that
does not require one to abandon their
faith or their beliefs
vice president harris's visit was quick
she left in the afternoon for a new
mexico campaign stop now the spokeswoman
for republican nevada gubernatorial
candidate joe lombardo had a reaction to
the vice president's visit in a
statement you see on your screen there
it says between nevada's astronomical
inflation rate and punishing cost of
living nevadans are desperate for
economic relief and competent leadership
yet all steve sisilek can give them is a
visit from kamala harris
nevada has the most permissive abortion
laws in the country other states are
passing more restrictive abortion laws
and that is forcing women to come here
in some cases from as far away as texas
for medical care david charns spoke with
planned parenthood votes nevada
executive director lindsey harmon
what does uh these reproductive rights
protections what what are we seeing here
in nevada when it comes to restrictions
in other states are are people coming
here
to seek these services we anticipate
that we will see a you know a pretty
large influx of patients coming in
um from states where
especially bordering states like
idaho and utah and arizona
as they start to go dark
we already have seen a large influx of
patients about half of our patients in
our three health centers here in nevada
are now out of state patients why do you
think that is that people are already
coming here um when i assume
there are some providers in some of
those states
now but the fear for them obviously is
that the
as you mentioned that they will be
unable to provide based on state laws so
why do you think we're already seeing
that influx
well i i think first it's important to
note that most of the patients we're
seeing are from texas
um where that six week ban was put in
place and that is before most um folks
know that they're pregnant so that's a
majority of the patients i think the
other half of that is people are really
scared right now i think there is um you
know you've seen the media coverage of
some of these cases that are now coming
to light
and so patients are terrified um and
they're pa they're terrified not only to
access care in their state that could be
you know potentially
ban that coverage in you know the coming
months but also because um there's been
a lot of conversations around medical
records and privacy and um who will have
access to that information and the civil
penalties and um you know the this kind
of vigilante um
uh culture out there in these in these
van states is terrifying people they're
um concerned that their neighbors and
friends and family could potentially
turn them in uh for seeking access to
care
so i think that's that's why you're
seeing a lot of folks you know travel
across state lines even you know uh
before some of these bans go into effect
is there a worry
you know for what you do every day that
there could be a national abortion ban
and what would that effect have on
nevada there are a lot of things that
can be done at the state level
that that also would kind of
maybe not interfere with the statute but
certainly would make it more difficult
for folks to access care especially
because we're worried about these
patients that are coming in from out of
state and the cooperative nature that
some states are
you know participating in across state
lines
i think that to your point and it's
really critically
important to remember that adam laxalt
in particular is running for senate
so we care about his vote at the federal
level and he that he will represent
nevadans um in a way that you know the
voting population has determined is the
way to go
um and we are you know
watching these federal bans these
restrictions on funding um and and
there's just so many ways that you can
um
can get at this issue that i think it's
naive of candidates to pretend that they
don't have a role to play here both at
the state level and the federal level
and again that was lindsey harmon with
planned parenthood votes nevada
the white house is pushing congress to
move quickly on president joe biden's
major spending package it has already
passed the senate and the house is
expected to vote on this on friday
though they hadn't yet by the time we
taped this program hannah brandt takes a
closer look at this legislation
the inflation reduction act is getting a
lot of praise from president biden
ordinary folks it makes a big investment
in climate programs and has provisions
to bring down health care costs but
republicans say the 740 billion dollar
price tag will make inflation worse not
better whenever you want to keep
borrowing more and more money from our
grandchildren keep printing dollars it's
going to be inflationary senator roger
marshall says the bill will drive up oil
costs kill jobs and disrupt supply
chains hard-working americans are going
to feel the impact of this tax and spend
bill white house economic adviser jared
bernstein disagrees republicans are just
blowing smoke he argues the package pays
for itself with provisions like a new 15
percent tax on wealthy corporations and
says many pieces of the bill will cut
costs for people like the new two
thousand dollar out of pocket cap on
prescription drugs for seniors those
people start saving four five six
thousand dollars a year clearly
disinflationary he also points to
analysis from the non-partisan
congressional budget office which says
the bill will actually raise extra
revenue for deficit reduction when
you're reducing the budget deficit
that's disinflationary some of the
measures won't take effect immediately
but the white house insists overall this
will make a difference some of it's not
going to kick in for a little bit but
it's all good
and that was hannah brandt reporting a
portion of the money will address
drought conditions in the southwest and
along the colorado river 4 billion
dollars will go towards things like dam
safety and water recycling 300 million
dollars over the next five years goes to
drought contingency planning on the
colorado river 250 million dollars of
that goes towards two rather goes to
conserve a hundred thousand acre feet of
water per year for comparison the states
have to announce between two and four
million acre feet worth of cuts next
week
despite being dubbed the inflation
reduction act most people don't think
that's what it's going to do an
economist you gov poll found just 12
percent of americans think this is going
to reduce inflation 40 percent think it
would increase inflation 23 percent
think it won't do a thing another biden
administration official was in las vegas
this week the head of the epa visited on
thursday during a trip to lake mead
michael reagan touted money going to the
colorado river and efforts to fight
drought he says most of the money will
be given out in the form of grants to
state and local water agencies
the best thing that epa can do is listen
to the people on the ground get
resources in their hand and put these
solutions to work we don't have a moment
to lose
some companion bills are also aimed at
upgrading research about drought on the
river here in the southwest
next on politics now stopping
unemployment fraud congressman stephen
horsford tells us about his new bill
aimed at fixing the unemployment system
plus former president trump's home
raided the reaction from capitol hill
and what the fbi was
[Music]
welcome back to politics now
more security for clark county school
district campuses at a school board
meeting this week 11 high schools were
chosen for upgrades all across ccsd the
changes range from about sixty thousand
dollars worth of changes to one point
five million dollars at again different
schools they include security cameras
fencing and single point entries
one parent says she's glad to see steps
being taken to keep her kids safe but
she wants to make sure all schools and
all students are protected
there shouldn't be any one more child
that is getting more safety than another
whether they're in this zip code or
another or whether they had a crime
incident last year or not every student
in clark county should be safe
this all comes about a month after
similar security upgrades were announced
over at el dorado high which is getting
26 million dollars invested into
security there you'll remember a teacher
was attacked and sexually assaulted
allegedly on campus last year last
school year clark high school is also
getting a hundred thousand dollars in
new infrastructure
this week trustees also approved a
financial settlement with superintendent
dr jesus jarrah ccsd agree agreed to pay
his legal fees last fall dr jarrah
claimed members of the board retaliated
against and harassed him before he was
fired a month later the board rescinded
the termination
dealing with drought on the colorado
river housing the economy they're all
issues on the minds of voters and this
week we spoke with nevada's democratic
congressman stephen horsford one of the
democratic congressmen and we started
with a discussion on his proposal to try
and cut down on unemployment fraud
let's talk about a measure that you've
put forward with regards to unemployment
fraud we've seen ppp loans we've seen so
much money flush into the system
and people struggling through the
pandemic tell me about your measure and
what you're hoping to achieve
so i've introduced the guard act it's
guaranteeing unemployment uh insurance
and addressing the deception
that's occurred with people's identities
being stolen
small businesses being targeted by these
criminal rings
it's something obviously we experienced
during the height of the pandemic when
we had some of the highest unemployment
in the country and i heard from
constituents who were affected both by
their
loss of their identity as well as the
delay in getting the benefits that they
were otherwise eligible for so this is
not unique only to nevada but we
unfortunately experienced some of the
worst of it let's switch gears a little
bit to another issue that people have
been dealing with before the pandemic
after the pandemic the issue of housing
i know later today there's going to be
some discussion of that that you're
involved in
on a federal level what can you in
congress do to try and address the
housing needs that we see all across
southern nevada all the time and you
probably see it all across the country
so i've introduced another bill called
the home act the housing oversight and
mitigating exploitation act i'm i was
born and raised here and so again i've
experienced the the growth that our
region has had but what i know recently
is that uh rental rates have gone up
nearly 30 percent in the last couple of
years
and when i
did research to really dig into what was
contributing to this what we found is
one and three
homes in parts of my congressional
district are now owned by these
out-of-state corporate speculators
people who companies who have come in
paid cash
they are now pricing out
nevadans
veterans
seniors first-time home buyers young
people
because they simply can't afford to buy
a home when someone's purchasing it from
cash on top of that these corporations
are also
evicting people at higher rates if they
are renting the properties and they have
a higher rate of not maintaining the
maintenance of those rental properties
which lowers the value throughout the
entire neighborhood so my bill would
empower hud to be able to go after these
corporate speculators address market
manipulation where it occurs
find them and then take the fines and
put them into the national housing trust
fund to actually develop more affordable
housing what kind of discussions are
happening with the other stakeholders on
the colorado to adjust how much they
pull from the colorado if you know
everyone keeps saying southern nevada
and nevada is doing its fair share well
it's not only about putting investment
into
mitigation of drought
it is about negotiation with the other
users and the allocation of water that
other states get we're doing both
the southern nevada water authority
general manager is involved in
negotiations
as we speak around
ensuring that nevada continues
to get our share of the water that's
necessary but we also need the
investment
because the climate crisis is real
drought and wildfires are occurring
there are things that we can do to
mitigate it or to address the water
shortage but it's going to take the
resources necessary
we also spoke with the congressman about
the inflation reduction act and you can
watch the entire interview at
eightnewsnow.com
more water cuts are on the horizon the
las vegas valley water district is
considering a trio of new rules the
first limits decorative water and
feature decorative water features i'm
sorry on the las vegas strip with a few
exemptions
the second cuts one third of the water
golf courses are allowed to use and the
third would put in tiered water rates
essentially the more you use the higher
the cost goes a vote on those plans
could come in october henderson and
north las vegas would have to pass
similar rules on their own
former president donald trump's home
raided next on politics now the reaction
from capitol hill and a little more
insight on what the fbi may have been
looking for
plus a judge quickly throws out joey
gilbert's lawsuit claiming he won the
nevada republican gubernatorial primary
his reason for doing
you're watching politics now
[Music]
this week attorney general merrick
garland addressed the fbi's execution of
a search warrant at former president
donald trump's mar-a-lago home garland
didn't say what the search warrant
specifically said however the new york
times reports it had to do with
documents not handed to the national
archive the washington post says it's
connected to nuclear weapon information
mr trump did confirm the raid but not
what they were looking for
garland says he personally signed off on
the warrant
first
i personally approved the decision to
seek a search warrant in this matter
second the department does not take such
decision lightly
where possible it is standard practice
to seek less intrusive means
as an alternative to a search
and to narrowly scope any search that is
undertaken
president joe biden says he was not told
about the search ahead of time here's
more on this from alexandre limon from
our washington dc bureau
what's been the reaction on capitol hill
so from democrats we're not hearing a
lot
they're saying they don't know much
about this investigation they only know
what's been reported publicly the same
things that the public is hearing
we even heard from the white house on
this and they said that president biden
was not given a heads up or alerted
ahead of time by the doj or the fbi that
that raid was going to happen
so democrats what they are saying though
is that they believe that no one is
above the law and that if president
trump former president trump did remove
any documents that shouldn't have been
removed from the white house
and moved them to mar-a-lago or other
places that this investigation should be
able to unfold the way any other
investigation would happen whether or
not he's a former president they say is
irrelevant because nobody is above the
law now republicans we've heard quite a
different reaction while we
have heard some agree that no one is
above the law
they're pretty skeptical about this they
they wonder if this could be politically
motivated they've questioned you know
the not only the motivations the timing
of this as we head into the november
elections uh we've heard some like
house leader kevin mccarthy call for
investigations of the doj congressional
investigations
and senator hawley even called for the
attorney general to resign i should
point out though that
as of now what we have seen so far and
what's happened so far that we know of
you know there isn't any real indication
that something like the attorney general
resigning is you know a realistic thing
that would happen and there appears so
far at least to be no reason for that to
happen alex simone from washington dc
thank you very much
nevada republican senate candidate adam
laxalt said in reaction to what took
place this week quote we don't live in a
third world country we live in america
he says today's raid it was early this
week of course the rate of mr trump's
home is just another example of the
growing weaponization of our federal
agencies left by the left while people
like hunter biden live freely his
opponent democratic senator catherine
cortez masto has not commented yet
joey gilbert's lawsuit claiming he won
the gubernatorial primary election on
the republican side has been thrown out
by a judge gilbert claimed that a math
equation proved he won when in fact he
lost by about 26 thousand votes to joe
lombardo
gilbert's attorneys had asked for a
recount with only paper ballots a carson
city judge ruled against them this week
and we'll see where it goes from here
in what to watch cuts to our water
supply on monday and tuesday we'll learn
just how much of our colorado river
water allotment will be cut and what
that could mean for mandatory cuts to
your lawn or maybe even your pool
plus on tuesday clark county
commissioners could move closer towards
the first pot lounges in southern nevada
approving the rules for giving out
licenses is on the agenda and after that
companies will have to apply and then
get approved to open those licenses or
open those lounges rather we could see
the first ones close to the end of the
year
we'll follow that and everything else in
politics right here on eight news now
we'll see you next week